le linxea open a débuté ce jeudi 6 mai
sous la pluie au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
le rendez vous organisé par la
fédération française de golf ou regroupe
près de 120 sportifs sur trois jours de
compétition le tournoi est mixte et il a
pour objectif de mêlée à la fois les
amateurs et les professionnels français
bien des amateurs pas partie moi je joue
avec deux amateurs de jeunes eux ça leur
permet de jouer avec des professionnels
ça leur permet de jouer sur un parcours
de compétition avec ba comme prévu un
temps assez compliqué ces amateurs
auront également le privilège de jouer
avec antoine ros nre le pensionnaire du
golf de la boulie à versailles
le numéro deux français est venu se
préparer avant de s'envoler pour des
tournois aux états unis très content
c'est un peu dommage avec la météo
voilà c'est comme ça je suis très
content c'est un très bon entraînement
pour moi le parcours est super donc non
très content de pouvoir faire de 3,18
euros ici au golf national
l'autre star de ce rendez vous sera
également le parcours les joueurs vont
se tester sur ce 18 trous qui a
accueilli les meilleurs joueurs du monde
pendant la ryder cup 2018 et la magie
opère toujours
bien qu'elle malheureux c'est un des
parcours le plus dur du français
après je pense qu'il ya plus dur mais
surtout avec les conditions de paris
c'est un golf historique le golfe depuis
la ryder cup est encore meilleur
qu'avant
donc oui forcément forcément c'est
vraiment un des moments privilégiés le
tournoi linxea open se terminera ce
samedi 8 mai sur les greens de
l'albatros le rendez vous se déroulera à
huis clos pendant l'ensemble de
l'épreuve